we are living through momentous times
the government is losing votes in the
House of Commons and next week it's 99%
certain they will lose the big one
where Parliament votes on mrs. Mayer's
plexy plan a lot of people who knew
what's happening as evidence that our
political system is in chaos but I think
what's happening is great for politics
and is exactly how representative
democracy should work
what MPs are doing is ignoring what
their leaders are telling them to do in
knowing what the whips are instructing
them to do and making up their own minds
on which way to vote they are
considering all the issues including how
their constituents voted in the
referendum and then deciding for
themselves that is true representative
democracy which for many many years in
this country has been distorted by the
first-past-the-post system and a party
system that rewards loyalty above all
else we should all be celebrating this
week something inspiring is coming out
of chaos I can't believe you think what
happened in the House of Commons this
week is good for democracy I say this is
the death of democracy this was never
supposed to be about what politicians
wanted this was supposed to be about
what the people of Britain wanted and it
sickens me to see vain arrogant
politicians trying to put together a
brexit that is totally against the
democratically declared will of the
people that they serve you and I let me
finish you still don't get what leave is
all about why people voted leave people
don't leave because they believe
politicians weren't listening to what
they had to say they believed that their
voices weren't being heard and the
reason there has been chaos over brexit
has been completely caused by
parliamentarians scrapping between
themselves and you said you're happy
about this now yes I'll bet you are
and I'll bet all the remainders in
Parliament are and I bet they all went
back to their big houses the other night
and let me finish and cracked open a
book a show
but I'm gonna but I'm answering what
you've just said yours was just as long
so don't be rude and just actually maybe
maybe is a Ramon even listen to what
someone else has to say Britt yeah not
you are people like you
toasting what has happened when have
come seeing this is fantastic
can we come someone else join in it for
working Pete's not it's totally so I'm
not toasting at all all I'm saying if
you actually listen celebrate was I'm
not arguing about breaks it at all what
I'm arguing about is parliamentary
democracy and arguing about the
individuals it for years and years the
people who run the parties I mean you
remember when play got elected saying
you're here because of Labor so please
do what we I tell you right this isn't
that this is a group of people who all
sitting around deciding what they should
do and they're taking into account they
were handed a mandate to fulfill a
certain task now the last time I got
divorced right
I instructed a lawyer go and sort out my
double she didn't come back to me my
lawyer and say you know what we spent
two-and-a-half years do you want to
think again no I want you to get the
best deal that you can and I hear what
you say but you know what
and I was you know I was a reluctantly
if I voted I've told you many times I
was probably 50 to 40 I didn't wake up
in the morning swivel-eyed with fury
over Brussels I just thought in the long
run actually be better for Britain to
get out I just wish that that steel
would get through ordinary people just
want the damn thing done Greg Lee even
though it's a bad deal it's a shocking
deal I get you not just getting down a
moobot let's just take a look at what
some of them mean let's get back to the
point I'm making let's just take a look
at what some of the room the Bexar tea
has said I mean if you look at Nigel
Farage well he said I believe in Britain
and Britain outside of the EU a proud
patriotic country that makes its own
laws in our own sovereign Parliament
Michael Gove said I believe as a matter
of deep principle in parliamentary
democracy I believe that the laws which
govern us should all be made by
politicians accountable Boris Johnson
who said the most valuable British
export and the one for which we are most
famous is the one that is now
increasingly in question parliamentary
democracy the way people express their
power
now that's what this is about this is
about a long last we have a we ever
going to have a period and it could will
end up we vote to leave or it could well
in that they vote that we should crash
out but at least they're not doing what
just because there's no instruction to
vary voted for what they believe we can
we we know what we know what you think
and please don't call us remain its it
just raises the temperature I can feel
my blood pressure spiking whenever you
do it stupid racist please what happened
was that dominic grievous much it's not
Parliament rejecting the will of the
people its Parliament trying to get this
done in a way that works for the country
now trees amazed deal is not there is a
majority for no there is no majority
trees amazed deal therefore we have to
look at this dispassionately what
dominant grief has done is to say that
MPs have a say in her statement to the
house if the deal is rejected can we
just hear from Dominic yes I think the
government should listen I have no
desire to undermine the Prime Minister
but at the end of the day we have to
accept we're a deeply divided country
where a deeply divided Parliament we are
going to have to find ways of working
through this and the best way of doing
that is offering people the real
opportunity to debate with each other
the options closing down options will
never work so Dominic group says people
what he means is MPs and in my heart
Carol and if this is going to make your
blood pressure rise what I would like
they are parliamentarians to do is to
use the Scottish Supreme Court's ruling
on article 50 that we can unilaterally
revoke article 50 revoke article 50 stop
brexit and that would give and that
would really give you something to mean
if you don't stop being root of ABS sick
of you being rude to me well I'm in this
debate as well can I just bring in a
grab please so this is a grab from
Valerie VARs Labour's shadow leader of
the Commons and what she's talking about
actually is about transparency which is
what I think this week
at every stage in this process the
government had sought to prevent
Parliament from having a meaningful say
on how this country approaches the
withdrawal from the EU the Prime
Minister has sought to sideline
Parliament but this amendment would
simply ensure that Parliament is given
another meaningful say if the government
lose on Tuesday next week isn't that
what our democracies about you know as a
lever you're always talking about
sovereignty well surely that is it in
action I don't understand I'm just like
what I was reacting to before was what
Rachel just said where she wants to
revoke the results of this and it's also
super lights don't mean important now
there used to be a pretense that they
were that they supported democracy and
their support of the will of the people
but now there is no pretenders anymore
they just don't okay I resent you
defining democracy solely as a
referendum result of 37% of the
electorate on it on an election that if
it was in Parliament the courts would
have become involved a long time ago
would not allow this result to stand we
can determine the future of our country
our children and our grandchildren for
the next 50 years
that was the terms of the referendum
actually when you think about it
the fact that we've probably got the
sort of deal that a 52-48 split merits
Parliament doing its job I'd honestly
don't know just to put the referenda to
put to put the result of the referendum
through to make it active nice a man you
can't do her deal as she calls it her
deal expressing the fact that the
executive has actually taken control of
this debate away from Parliament in our
Parliament is simply saying they'll exit
here I think at the moment I'd vote for
me she's amazed you absolutely because
it's the best sugar because it's the
best you're going to get and the
hardline breaks it is are risking all
yes their entry there yeah build about
never being abrasive they could they
create yes they could lose if it's
excuse me I'm amazed that they haven't
just said
look we don't like this deal but it's
the beginning she's writing the sense of
fear for basic fundamentals are what the
Plex it was about nightly with her I I
told didn't have another big sit here
but if I was a brexit ear now I'd be
voting for this fantasy of the picker
mix that we were sort of promised you
ain't ever gonna get there if you don't
vote for this one you're never gonna get
there is my dear so you think when it is
reaches cus this no doubt next week but
if you think this if it doesn't go
through on Tuesday you think it's
finished I think she needs to go into
the jungle I need you to I need you to
agree to disagree cuz we've got no deal
on that we don't we don't